marty is with us in New York hey Marty
how are you good Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up I'm so I'm
sitting for a house would you invest
into mutual funds to see for the house
or will you just stack your cash and go
from there five years or more I would
probably use an index fund five years or
less I wouldn't mm-hmm and the next one
is will be better than mutual funds an
index fund is a mutual fund it's a it's
a no load S&P 500 fund it's gonna follow
the market exactly and it's gonna grow
without you paying any taxes on the
growth until you pull it out and if it's
been in there longer than one year you
will only pay capital gains rate on the
growth of 15% rather than 40 percent or
30 percent or whatever your income tax
rate is so it's a great way to grow
money I park money in index funds for
short-term use like a five-year a
two-year three-year goal I can't afford
for it to turn down when like the market
is right now and not worry about it I'll
just hold my breath and well it comes
back up before I buy something with that
money but since it's your big deal it's
your house fund I don't want to put it
at risk and the market goes up in the
market goes down it is at risk but I
don't want to put it I don't want I know
the statistics on over 90 percent of the
funds make money
over 90 percent of five year periods in
the stock markets history have made
money so over 90 percent of time in
history if you'd put it in and left it
alone five years or more you would have
made money but only 67 percent of the
time he would make money if he left it
in only three years so you start and
would you this is the short of the term
the bigger chance yargh of losing money
and I don't want you to do that and
would you not put any away for
retirement at the same time but just
keep on going for that goal of getting a
house or would you put some to
retirement at the same time I would put
some towards retirement if you're going
to save for over three years if you can
do your down payment in three years or
less which would put you back into CDs
not in our money markets not in not in
mutual funds but I don't want to I don't
want to zero
retirement for more than three years if
you're going to save super long like
that then there we go hey thanks for
joining us